Hôm nay không hỏa bánh giả.
Ná đối mạnh tưởng nhắm rồi, ngồi lạc, không gà không khá bằng bà.
Cô nói cái chánh động, không cần chà dụt, không cần bỏ thợ,
mấy sật sẽ xích bóc của mối.
Lựng một coi bột giá chị về chục nghi của thế thấy thế bản tay của tự lần nghi.
Cô hỏi này đã có y ra một lần sống trên cãi mạnh mấy,
đặc biệt là tụi các xin gia địa lạnh.
Trong những cình gần đây, các mình tạm mạng sợ hội đang đừng bộ với hàng loạt video
còn bá sân phòng buộc vệ sinh đồng giật sự hóc.
Nhưng người đui kiến phạc kế ông ảo đồng rạc chia sẻ về việc qua thân ký của sản phòng này.
Những lời còn khá hấp sẫn đã thú sửa tòm mỏ của đồng đảo như tư dùng.
Nhưng đầm sông những lời cá người có kánh đó, sự thật là gì?
Bức sử dụt bộ về sinh đầy vô cùng đơn giản, chỉ cần đủ bộ vào mái,
cho chỉ đủ về sinh lòng giật và nhìn nước.
Nếu tất, nước trong đồng giật chuyển tư trong theo xác mầu đục nổ,
thật chi có thể thấy các mạm mắm, cạnh bình đổi lệng đầy.
Đây là giống hiệu cho tế sình phòng đong phát vý tác dụt,
sau khi xả nước, lông giật đá sách thương đáng ký.
Mày giật thực sự xác xương và hỏng đồng giữa qua,
giúp bản thịt kịt thử dân và công suốt.
Sản phẩm này đang hiện đu vui văn phần mùi tích thực tư cộng mạm của hộ đánh giản năm sau.
Nhưng thấy cảm nhận này sức mạnh của việc sinh lòng giật xác mạm,
không chừng, ui tín, mô ngày tải đây.